je peux vous donner le sentiment qu'on
éprouve du coup vu de bruxelles
oui du jamais vu avec une campagne qui
pour le moment n'est pas une campagne
centrée sur le fond et avec une famille
politique la famille politique du centre
droit qui se trouve dans un très grand
désarroi est incapable de développer un
projet et est ramené à des sujets qui
sont des sujets judiciaire avec c'est
vrai ce sentiment d'une très grande
division de cette famille d'une très
grande volonté à vous inquiète de deux
vraiment continuer de françois fillon
malgré une procédure judiciaire qui dans
d'autres pays
or et c'est quoi cette renaissance
nationale corps une fois je ne veux pas
moi me prononcer avec acharnement manana
vont comprendre votre réserve
vous avez été directeur de campagne pour
françois hollande en 2012 je vais le
dire 'tiens mine je vais lire
différemment je suis un homme de gauche
je suis un européen
je suis un français et il est important
que la famille de la droite et du centre
qui est une famille politique importante
puisse mener campagne en développant un
projet en ayant sa forme d'unité autour
d'un candidat qui va de l'avant et là on
voit bien qu'elle est entravée et dès
lors que cette famille politique est
entravée il y à quelque chose
d'essentiel qui manque au débat
politique en france